يا سلام منذ نحوي عام انقلبت حياته
الكبيره والزاهيه راسنا على عقب حلم
الابناء بالهجره وبناء مستقبل مشرق حول
حياه اسرهم الى كابوس بشكل مفاجئ انقطع في
ديسمبر الماضي التواصل مع مجموعه تضم نحو
30 شابا كانوا يحاولون الهجره لاوروبا
انطلاقا من تونس
كم رنا
كل واحد من هؤلاء في حي البرنوصي بالدار
البيضاء يفتقد عزيزا ابنا او اخا او حفيدا
ابوابارقه الامل للامهات المشكله
في تعقبه لاثر المفقودين سافر محمد صوف
الى تونس هناك التقى السفير المغربي وراسل
السلطات القضائيه التونسيه وجمع قدرا غير
يسير من المعلومات
الى اوروبا تختاروا شبكات الهجره غير
النظاميه طرقا عديده انطلاقا من المغرب
ينتقل الساعون الى الهجره الى تونس لتصيد
اللحظه المناسبه للابحار شمالا وفي رحله
اخرى محفوفه بالمخاطر يتخذوا مهاجرون
السواحل الليبيه منطلقا للوصول الى الجنوب
الاوروبي كما اضيفت في السنوات الاخيره
تركيا الى المسارات التي يختارها
المهاجرون للوصول الى اوروبا عبر الاراضي
اليونانيه
في العاصمه الرباط سلط اولياء الامور
الضوء على قضيتهم وطلبوا من الدول
المغاربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي الكشف عن
مصير ابنائهم واطلاقا المحتجزين منهم
هو وجه اخر لماسي الهجره غير النظاميه ماس
ستتواصل فصولها ما دامت اسبابها قائمه
والى ان تزولا هذه الاسباب جزئيا او كليا
سيتظل اسر الضحايا تدفع فاتوره هذه
الظاهره حزنا وكندا المختار الجزيره
الرباط